now this is just for anybody watching at
the end of the day
simple breakdown I provide for people is
if you're if you're if you're a man
for any man in this room if I was to sit
here and break down a woman so for
example
I would say she's
she's very very caring she loves her
career yeah right she's very very driven
she's got loads of friends around her
that love and respect to her family
adores at a piece is highly educated
what is every single man in this room
thinking right now
in what sense if I was to describe a
woman and start off and purely lay out
those
um attributes or traits or her history
right what what for any guy in here or
any guy listening what question do you
have in mind what's the first question
you have what does she look like thank
you very much right it all comes down to
the Aesthetics in the beginning right
now for women it is slightly different
in that
now if I was to say
he's a great looking guy
chisel jaw big dick
tall
why what does he do well thank you very
much yeah you've broke so the first
thing you want to know who is he what
does he do what is connections what's
his status right in society I think deep
down every single woman asks those
questions and if I was to say along with
those things
if I was to drop it on you now say that
he's a complete bum he's going nowhere
in life he still lives in his mum's
basement and he's got no drive to
accomplish anything in life nobody
around him respects him he's got no
friends and there's no girls trying to
hit him up what would you say now
I hope to God you guys don't want to
date bones so you're saying guys would
like a girl who's bummy yes
what a girl a woman being a bum to us
well we don't really look at women as
bums for us it's more to do with your
loyalty yeah and it's to do with your
attitude in life whether you're arrogant
whether you've got that overly confident
nature to us it's repulsive but a woman
having no money
and a woman not being well connected do
you think we give a [ __ ] because that's
not our ultimate goal ultimately on a
DNA level and this is what most men need
to understand this is what we act on
it's Primal it's on a DNA level we are
ultimately after
good breeding stock so you need to have
and this is this is a woman's display of
good breeding stock good genes is by
having a great physique a beautiful face
she's youthful she's young she's within
that Peak fertility window
she does have a clock the sooner like
that that will run out and then she'll
she'll end up on the other side of that
where men are now not looking at her for
sex they're not looking at for
biological reasons maybe for Value as
far as being a great nanny or for
example being great with kids being
valuable in different areas but we are
not looking at you and thinking I'm
gonna get good good kids with good genes
out if you once you're past that window
and that is even more sorry for
menopause
yeah because geriatric pregnancy starts
at 35 so your options start to run out
they don't recommend having a kid over
what like 37 38 nice and when the
studies I've read is between
around 1617 to around early 30s is when
they say is a woman's Peak fertility
yeah but and the problem is you have
rich people pushing a luxury Lifestyle
on average people like geriatric or um
IVF which is something like girls always
say it's 25 000 who has that lying
around and you have rich people that can
do that right like the Kardashians they
all had kids later in life they're fine
but it's because they could afford to
the average girls can't do that and so
you have feminism pushing like Chase the
bag chase the career get ran through and
and basically piss away your the most
valuable thing you have which is your
Youth and your fertility not only that
PO what what tends to happen is that I
feel like there's an agenda in terms of
there is a benefit to to certain people
that women are single not in control of
their finances spending and they've got
money so they've got they've got
um a lot of money coming in they're not
tied down but they're spending money
somewhere so yeah because seven women
make 70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions and so there is an agenda in
keeping women single right because
you're not going to buy no big Burkin
bag when you're in a race well women
women women make less money but spent
own two-thirds of the world's debt even
though we make ten to fifteen thousand
dollars pounds less than men per year
and so we have less money and we spend
more
[Music]
um
yeah we're impulsive yeah yeah but it's
because we're chemically different we
can't we can't help it we have salt but
we're adults but like like on some
Primal level we're chemically different
every day
so like we're we're more like emotional
beings yeah yeah we're more likely to
respond to to make impulsive decisions
that's what it is and your friends are
not going to help you because she wants
to make those decisions as well so it's
like the only person that's really there
is the guy that's just like the cheap
guy that we called it you know I'm
saying he's controlling the final like
no you can't keep doing this babe yeah
you know I mean like we can't afford it
we need distant distance
so I have I have a question for the
women would you okay if you had a guy I
I don't I know it varies for every girl
so imagine a guy that has every single
thing that you want like perfect guy
would you overlook cheating from time to
time just a side chick no I would you
would you'd Overlook it I wouldn't you
wouldn't even if also your bills are
taken care of completely till you die I
wouldn't you wouldn't okay
I wouldn't
um if I had kids it might be different
but yeah if I didn't have kids
um and I was still I felt like
if I was still like maybe my age now um
yeah I I wouldn't Overlook it because a
trait that I look for is loyalty and for
me I understand that the male nature is
to spread his seed you know go find out
what like what he wants and
yeah so I I can understand that but I
also think that them giving into that
nature of you know like even if it
didn't mean anything it was just like a
one night stand you know he was just
caught up in the moment that to me would
be like you're you're a weak man you
can't hold like especially if we had
some really good going on and we had a
really good relationship we've been
together a really long time and
and then you just [ __ ] up one night
but that to me is disrespectful to me
and then I wouldn't go back with you
because now you would probably do that
again because I've accepted that that's
how you are now you [ __ ] up from time to
time can I just ask have you been in
that position before
no I've never been to eat done
so for you why did you say yes
I don't believe that men can not cheat
okay and when I say men I mean most men
I think I think I think they're just
built to
um
you mean we're not designed we're not
designed to be with one person we're not
designed to cheat because you're
assuming that the woman is like somehow
like deservant of just me alone no no
like what makes you think aren't desire
to be monogamous that's not her words
hey let her say what she said she said
she really has let her talk she said
cheat guys let her talk go ahead go
ahead
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible